there's a certain desperation and a
certain hunger for money in our society
it's the people are so desperate for how
to figure that out that even when they
know that this thing is probably scammy
it's probably a waste of time this guy
probably doesn't know what he's talking
about he might have a good tidbit in
there right they're so desperate and
it's it's a little sad because making
money as i was saying it's an inevitable
byproduct of learning
it's difficult because like the answer
is it's it's
like
it's simple we know what we need to do
to be successful in all of the different
fields we know how to be a good writer
right a lot we know how to be a good
startup person like find customers
understand them solve a problem build a
product we just these things are just
hard
and so we looked for like oh maybe these
other things matter but like we all kind
of know what matters like we kind of
know what's necessary in order to
succeed in many different pursuits
uh
it's just like every you know everyone
knows how to have a six-pack everyone
knows how to get ripped
that information has been out there for
a long time uh so what we really want is
we want people to just show that they've
actually done it they've put in the work
and the time they've taken the risk
they've got to the truth what makes
someone healthy what actually works and
then the their output is just evidence
that they got to the truth
and that's and that's sort of the
yeah you don't want a sick doctor or a
fat trainer or
my favorite is these uh
life coaches whose own lives are in
shambles or these executive coaches
would never build a business
the unfortunate part is like a truly
great executive coach should have built
a successful business
and those people are generally unhirable
or they're extremely expensive
of course all the people selling get
rich quick advice you know for 20 like
that's all complete nonsense all the
people giving you stock tips or crypto
tips on twitter complete nonsense um
these are all fake signals it's
surprising to me actually how many
people fall for them it's kind of sad
well yeah why why do you think people
fall for them is it like is it just like
at sort of each tier of this of the game
like every status tier they're sort of
like you it actually makes sense to play
the status game to get to the top to
kind of get to the next phase or how do
you think about that
well there's some
there's some amount of
um unfakable knowledge or unbiable
knowledge there's something that just
cannot be purchased in the market right
so what can't be purchased in the market
that i would tweet about this that i
often refer back to myself which is
you know a fit body a calm mind and a
house full of love these things cannot
be bought
they must be earned and so those three
things are things that you are unfakable
signals you have to go and get them
yourself regardless of how much money
you have
um and we're used to kind of getting
everything in our lives of money even
though we can't get those three things
there's actually a fourth one that's a
little more subtle um
which is important which i would just
call kind of i don't have a good name
for it but it's sort of just knowledge
about how to like deal with situations
you can't initially buy that judgment
let's call it judgment right so let's
say that for example that um you are you
know this happened your friend of mine
recently he broke his ankle okay and he
has to decide whether or not to get
surgery
and of course if he goes to the surgeons
they all say yeah you need surgery and
if he goes to non-surgeon doctors or you
know
people who are doing yoga or massages
they'll say well massages are good for
your yoga will fix you so it's very and
he has a short period of time to figure
out whether or not to get the surgery
before his ankle could potentially
repair you know heal in a in a way
that's catastrophic in the long term so
he no amount of money will help him make
this decision because he he's not an
expert in ankles himself so he has to
figure out who to trust and it's the who
to trust problem that is the core
problem it's like for example if you're
president of states and you're in the
country and the nsa comes up to you and
says you know russia's about to attack
us we need to sneak attack them first
and the cia comes in and says no
actually this is a fake signal don't
listen to the nsa like how is the
president going to know right he doesn't
because he doesn't have his own core
expertise in the topic so it becomes a
very difficult situation so there's
certain kinds of knowledge and judgment
that just cannot be bought with any
amount of money you just have to figure
it out you have to figure out who to
trust it's the picking experts problem
so anyway those four things which is
knowledge that helps you make decisions
aka judgment uh plus a healthy body plus
a calm mind plus you know a loving
household these things you just have to
work at them and so the
the one remaining thing which is money
is the universal adapter right that
money can solve pretty much every other
problem so people know that so they want
the money and there's a certain
desperation and a certain hunger for
money in our society which i kind of
feel bad about which is why i did you
know partially all the how to get rich
work to help people figure out the
principles of making money or creating
wealth i should say um
it's the people are so desperate for how
to figure that out that even when they
know that this thing is probably scammy
it's probably a waste of time this guy
probably doesn't know what he's talking
about he might have a good tidbit in
there right they're so desperate and
it's it's a little sad because making
money as i was saying it's an inevitable
byproduct of learning
and that's not the road people are able
to go down a lot of times they've
already completed a university degree
might be a single mom might not have any
avenue to make money might be a factory
worker might be a starbucks what have
you and they're like oh man i really
really need to figure out how to break
out of this i need to figure out how to
make real money and these people are
desperate and so then it's like okay
well you know i'll spend the 20 bucks
i'll go to the seminar this guy he does
seem to dress well he does drive a
sports car
maybe he has some clue but they don't
even know where to start and i feel bad
for those people and you know thanks to
eric and the almanac existence out there
and hopefully people will read at least
some principles of wealth creation
and at least at a high level be able to
you know make some good decisions and
differentiate from
charlatans and get rich quick schemes
from
from having real judgment real learning
that can help them make money and
learning leverage leverage is actually
the biggest piece of it
accountability great you can make it big
without accountability
even specific knowledge like very
important but you can actually make it
without specific knowledge but if you
have if you don't have leverage you're
never going to make real wealth so
leverage is actually probably the most
important component of the principles
i've discussed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
you